foreign
this is Professor mdas science and today
we will discuss the spectral series of
the hydrogen atom in another one of our
videos on rigorous condom mechanics when
an atom transitions from a higher to a
lower energy state it emits a photon the
study of these emitted photons is the
subject of spectroscopy which provides
key insights into the atomic energy
levels the emission spectrum of the
hydrogen atom was actually discovered
before the development of a full atomic
theory and it therefore played a key
role in the development of quantum
mechanics for historical reasons the
emission spectrum of hydrogen is divided
into series which depend on the energy
levels that are involved you may have
actually heard of some of these theories
for example the Lyman series or the
bomber Series in this video we are going
to show how the emission spectrum of
hydrogen emerges from the quantum
mechanical description of the system but
we will also explore some interesting
features of the hydrogen spectral series
such as how they lead to the red color
that we see in Cosmic nebulas so let's
go
the hydrogen atom is made of two
particles a proton and an electron in
our earlier videos on hydrogen we found
that the key physics of the system is
encoded by the relative motion of the
proton and the electron that means that
we can describe the hydrogen atom with a
one particle relative hamiltonian H with
the usual kinetic energy term and a
potential energy term that describes the
coulomb interaction
in the position representation we can
rewrite it with the usual kinetic energy
term gradient and the potential energy
term which has the form of a central
potential
for full derivation you should check out
the introductory video on the hydrogen
atom but just to remind you mu here is
the reduced mass of the system and is
related to the masses of the proton and
electron by this equation
B here is the relative momentum given by
this expression in terms of the
individual momenta of the proton and the
electron and R is the relative position
which is given by the distance between
the proton and the electron
so starting with this relative
hamiltonian we can write its eigenvalue
equation like this
where as usual these are the eigenvalues
and these are the eigenfunctions
we've solved this eigenvalue equation to
determine all the bound days of the
hydrogen atom in a series of very
mathematical videos that we've Linked In
the description and you should go there
and check them out for all of the
details what we will do today is to
focus on the eigenvalues
in our mathematical solution we found
that the energy eigenvalues en are given
by minus e i Over N squared
the eye is called the ionization energy
and is given by this expression in terms
of the reduced mass of the proton
electron system and some fundamental
physical constants
its numerical value is about 13.6
electron volts
and additionally the quantum number n
called the principal quantum number can
only take positive integer values and
labels the different energy eigenvalues
of hydrogen
again do check out the videos Linked In
the description for the full details
Behind These expressions
starting from these energy eigenvalues
the aim of today's video is to explore
the emission spectrum of the hydrogen
atom
when an atom transitions from a high
energy eigenstate to a lower energy
eigenstate a photon is emitted whose
energy is equal to the energy difference
between the two states
the collection of all possible emitted
photons is called the emission spectrum
of the atom and the study of these
emitted photons is the subject of
spectroscopy which provides key
information about the atomic energy
levels
in today's video we will explore the
emission spectrum of the hydrogen atom
which played a key role in the
development of quantum theory
we're going to consider a hydrogen atom
in an initial energy eigenstate N2 and a
final energy eigenstate N1 the
transition between the two states is
accompanied by the emission of a photon
and will label its energy with Delta re
note that for remission we always need
N2 to be larger than N1
the energy of the photon is equal to the
energy difference between the two energy
levels and can be written as en2 minus E
N1
using the expression for the energy
eigenvalues at the top here we can
rewrite it as this expression for en2
minus this expression for en1
rearranging we end up with the
ionization energy multiplying one over
N1 squared minus 1 over N2 squared
this means that when the hydrogen atom
transitions from energy level N2 to
energy level N1 a photon of this energy
Delta e is emitted
it is common practice to describe the
emitted Photon using its wavelength
rather than its energy so we will now
convert this expression accordingly
remember that we can relate the energy
and wavelength of a photon via this
equation which involves the Planck
constant H and the speed of light C
we can next insert this expression for
the photon energy into this expression
and we end up with this equation
rearranging we find that the inverse
wavelength is equal to this prefactor
times 1 over N1 squared minus 1 over N2
squared
we now collect the pre-factor here into
a new constant RH
and with this we arrive at the ridberg
formula which gives us the inverse of
the emitted Photon wavelength as equal
to this expression
and remember that N2 is larger than N1
for remission
the ridberg formula is named after
Johannes ritberg who first proposed it
empirically in 1888 before the
development of quantum mechanics our
approach today has been from the bottom
up and we've derived the ridberg formula
from the basic Quantum properties of the
hydrogen atom
so the constant RH here is called the
ridberg constant so let's copy it down
remembering the expression we have for
the ionization energy
we can use it to rewrite the rydberg for
constant like this
remembering that H bar is equal to H
over 2 pi we can combine these terms to
get 4H squared and we end up with this
alternative expression for our age
the ridberg constant was first
introduced empirically as a fitting
parameter to The observed emission
spectrum of hydrogen and only later was
it related to the fundamental constants
as we have right here in front of us
to determine the numerical value of the
ritberg constant we just need a few
values the effective Mass mu of the
proton electron system is equal to
9.104 times 10 to the minus 31 kilograms
and we derive this value in detail in
the video on the ground state of the
hydrogen atom we also need the
fundamental charge e equal to 1.602
times 10 to the minus 19 coulomb the
permittivity of free space which is
equal to
8.854 times 10 to the minus 12 meters to
the power of minus 3 kilogram to the
power of minus one second to the power
of 4 and amperes squared
then the plan constant is equal to 6.626
times 10 to the minus 34 Joule second
and the speed of light which is equal to
2.998 times 10 to the 8 meters per
second
using these numerical values and in fact
using a few more significant figures
than those shown here we find that the
ritber constant up here is approximately
equal to
1.09678 time 10 to the 7 inverse meter
this is the ripberg constant associated
with a hydrogen atom and it is the one
that we will use today
however as a quick aside in your study
of atomic physics you will often
encounter a related constant which is
also confusingly called the Red Bar
constant but it's labeled as R Infinity
our Infinity is simply the river
constant in the limit that the reduced
mass of the proton electron system tends
to the electron Mass
an alternative but equivalent way to
think of this is that it's the limit in
which the proton Mass becomes infinitely
large which is often useful to
conceptually understand the behavior of
the hydrogen atom as then we can just
view it as simply an electron moving
around a stationary proton
so in this context we can write the new
redback constant as equal to this
expression where we are simply replacing
the reduced mass by the electron mass
and its numerical value is
1.09737 times 10 to the 7 inverse meter
so really close to the value of Rh
so we can use this expression to
determine the wavelength of an emitted
Photon when the hydrogen atom
transitions from energy level N2 to
energy level and one
the different values that N1 and N2 can
take give many possible Photon
wavelengths and the collection of all
these is called the emission spectrum of
hydrogen
historically the emission spectrum of
hydrogen has been divided into groups
called series
each emission series which is also
called spectral series is characterized
by the level N1 in which the atom ends
up after the transition
so in the rest of the video we will go
over the few possible values of N1 to
study the most famous spectral series of
hydrogen
let's start with N1 equals 1 which is
the ground state
this spectral series therefore
corresponds to Transitions from any
excited state to the ground state and
it's called the Lyman series and it was
discovered by Theodore Lyman in 1906.
if we insert N1 equals 1 into the
expression at the top we get that the
inverse Photon wavelength is equal to
the ritberg constant times 1 minus 1
over N2 squared
and as N2 must be larger than N1 it can
take any value starting from 2 3 4 5 and
so on in integer steps
let's draw a table with N2 in the First
Column and the wavelength in the second
column
as is conventionally done we're going to
use nanometers as the unit of length and
just as a quick reminder one nanometer
is equal to 10 to the minus 9 meters
all we have to do to get the wavelengths
of the Lyman series is to insert the
numerical values into this expression
and we will go straight to the answer
when the hydrogen atom is in the first
excited state then N2 equals 2. in this
case we get a wavelength of 1 to 1.56
nanometers
when the hydrogen atom is in the second
excited state we have N2 equals three in
this case we have an emitted proton
wavelength of 102.57 nanometers
4 and 2 equals 4 we get 97.25 nanometers
for N2 equals five we get
94.97 nanometers 4 and 2 equals six we
get
93.78 nanometers and we could go on like
this and eventually in the limit of very
large N2 the wavelength tends to
91.17 nanometers
each of these transitions corresponds to
a spectral line in the emission spectrum
of hydrogen and together they form the
Lyman series
the different Lines within the series
are labeled by Greek places in
alphabetical order so the first would be
the Lyman Alpha line the second would be
the Lyman beta line then the Lyman gamma
then the lime and Delta then the Lyman
Epsilon and so on the final one is
called the Lyman limit which is the
photon wavelength that caps the Lyman
series
let's remember the expression for the
photon energy
for the Lyman series with N1 equals one
then when N2 becomes very large we end
up with the photon energy tending to the
ionization energy
this makes perfect sense the Lyman
series corresponds to Transitions to the
ground state and The Binding energy of
the ground state is the ionization
energy therefore if we have a hydrogen
atom with N2 tending to Infinity it
means that this atom is At the limit of
being bound so its transition to the
ground state will release a photon whose
energy is equal to the ionitation energy
we're now going to draw the spectral
series of hydrogen let's draw a
horizontal line which corresponds to the
photon wavelength as a reference we're
going to include the visible spectrum
which runs roughly between 400
nanometers and 700 nanometers
for lower wavelengths we get the
ultraviolet or UV region
and for longer wavelengths we get the
infrared or IR region
we're now going to draw the lineman
series on this axis so from the previous
slide we can place the first line in the
lineman series The Lymon Alpha line here
as it corresponds to
121.56 nanometers displays it well
within the UV range
we can also place the second line here
the third here the fourth the fifth and
so on all the way to the lineman limit
which is here and corresponds to 91.17
nanometers
this diagram shows that the entire
lineman series Falls within the UV range
of the electromagnetic spectrum
as none of the lines are in the visible
part of the spectrum the Lyman series
was not the first one to be discovered
historically that honor corresponded to
the Balmer series
the bomber series corresponds to
Transitions from higher excited state to
the first excited state which is N1
equals two
some of these spectral lines in the
series have been known for a while but
it is named after Johann bauma who
discovered an empirical formula to
relate the different wavelengths in this
series in 1885.
the formula discovered by bomber is
simply a special case of the ridberg
formula if we insert N1 equals 2 into
the ridberg formula at the top we get
that the inverse Photon wavelength is
equal to the rydberg constant times 1
over 4 minus 1 over N2 squared
and as N2 must be larger than in one it
can take any value starting from three
four five six and so on in integer steps
so let's again draw a table with N2 in
the First Column and the wavelength in
the second column again using nanometers
as the unit of length
the series starts at N2 equals three
which gives a wavelength of
656.46 nanometers
and 2 equals 4 gives
486.27 nanometers N2 equals 5 gives
434.19 nanometers and 2 equals six gives
410 points 29 nanometer and uh N2 equals
seven gives
397.12 nanometers
we could go on like this and eventually
in the limit of very large N2 the
wavelength tends to
364.84 nanometers
each of these transitions corresponds to
a spectral line in the emission spectrum
of hydrogen and they all together form
the bomber series
using the same convention that we had
for the lineman series the first line
would be the bammar alpha line then Baba
beta then bandwagamma and so on
however the bomber series is sometimes
also simply labeled by the chemical
symbol for the hydrogen atom so that the
first line would be the H Alpha the
second would be the H beta then H gamma
and so on
the reason why the symbol H is also used
for the bomber series is because this
was the first Hydrogen spectral series
that was discovered
so let's go back to our picture of the
electromagnetic spectrum
we're now going to draw the bomber
series we can place the first line of
the Bama series The Balmoral for line
right here as it corresponds to
656.46 nanometers
this places it within the visible
spectrum with a red color
we can place the second line here and it
also falls within the visible spectrum
in particular it will have a blue color
third goes here and it will be Violet
the fourth goes here and it's also
Violet The Fifth Line Falls here and it
is really close to the boundary between
the visible and the UV parts of the
electromagnetic spectrum
we could go on like this and we would
reach the barber limit which was right
here at
364.84 nanometers
this diagram shows that the first few
lines of the bomber series fall within
the visible range of the electromagnetic
spectrum and these lines were the first
emission lines of hydrogen to be
discovered the series then goes into the
UV region of the spectrum where it ends
if we were to look with the naked eye at
the emission spectrum of the large-scale
structures of the universe such as
nebulous then the first line of the
Balmer series the H Alpha line in the
red region here would be really
prominent
hydrogen is the most abundant element in
the universe and as such it's emission
lined in the visible range of the
electromagnetic spectrum tell us a lot
about what the universe looks like to
the naked eye for example the H Alpha
line gives the red color that is so
commonly seen in Star forming nebulas
such as the Orion Nebula that you can
see all around me
you can now probably see how the rest of
the story unravels the next spectral
series corresponds to N1 equals three
and it's called the passion series named
after Friedrich passion who discovered
it in 1908.
going straight to the table this time I
will skip the details and directly fill
it in for the first few lives of the
series all the way to the limiting line
so going back to our picture of the
Electoral magnetic Spectrum we have now
zoomed out from our previous version to
be able to fit it to the new series
including the passion series it starts
here at around 1880 nanometers and it
goes on like this terminating here at
around 820 nanometers
this places the entire fashion series
within the infrared region of the
electromagnetic spectrum
the next spectral series corresponds to
N1 equals four and it's called the
bracket series named after Friedrich
bracket who discovered it in 1922.
going straight to the table we can fill
it up in the usual way
so now we go back to our plot of the
electromagnetic spectrum and we have
again zoomed out to be able to fit the
new series the bracket series which
starts at around 4050 nanometers and
goes on like this terminating at around
1460 nanometers
this places the entire bracket series
within the infrared region of the
electromagnetic spectrum and we see that
the bracket series overlaps with the
previous series which is the passion
series
the next spectral series corresponds to
N1 equals five and it's called the fund
series named after August fund who
discovered it in 1924.
going straight to the table we can fill
it up in the usual way
and then we go back to the plot of the
electromagnetic spectrum we have the
usual zoom out and now we will add the
font series
it starts at around
7460 nanometers and it goes on like this
and it terminates at around
2290 nanometers
this places the entire fun series within
the infrared region of the
electromagnetic spectrum and we see that
it overlaps with the previous series
the next spectral series corresponds to
N1 equals six and it's called the
Humphrey series named after Curtis
Humphries who discovered it in 1953.
and we complete the table in the usual
way
going back to our figure of the
electromagnetic spectrum we will now add
the Humphrey series it starts at around
12 370 nanometers and it goes on like
this terminating at around
3290 nanometers and this places the
entire Humphreys series within the
infrared region of the electromagnetic
spectrum and we see that it also
overlaps with the previous series
we could honestly go on like this for
higher values of N1 but the subsequence
series no longer have specific names so
we won't go on but you can do it
yourself if you want by simply using the
ridberg formula as we've been doing for
the series that are shown in the diagram
to finish we're going to talk about how
the spectral series that we've discussed
today are not the full story regarding
the emission spectrum of the hydrogen
atom
in our study of the hydrogen atom so far
we've been using a non-relativistic
hamiltonian although relativistic
effects are small in hydrogen modern
spectroscopic techniques do allow us to
measure the small relativistic
corrections to the predictions that
arise from the non-relativistic
hamiltonian that we've been discussing
today
these relativistic terms lead to the
so-called fine structure and hyperfine
structure of hydrogen
the fine structure leads to this
splitting of some of the spectral lines
we've been discussing today into closely
spaced lines
the hyperfine structure also leads to
additional lines a very prominent one
being this 21 centimeter hydrogen line
this hydrogen line is frequently
observed in this radio astronomy because
electromagnetic radiation of this
wavelength can penetrate into Cellar
dust while for example visible light
cannot do so
the spectral series of hydrogen played a
crucial role in the development of the
quantum theory today we've seen how they
emerge from a basic understanding of the
energy levels of hydrogen and that's
where we're going to stop today and as
always if you like the video please
subscribe
foreign